as many of you know intel the company
that for many years enjoyed a monopoly
over the cpu industry
isn't doing so well anymore consumers
who once defended intel with all of
their might on various internet forums
have slowly faded away and the worst
part is that the future for intel
is starting to look incredibly grim but
to be honest this shouldn't surprise
anybody we've known that intel was in
trouble for years now
in fact back in 2019 almost a full year
before
apple officially announced their
transition from intel
chips we made this video and the funny
thing about the thumbnail
is that it's actually starting to become
reality in that video
we made a couple of predictions on how
intel would eventually end up
fighting for the life of their business
and so far
half of it has already come true so let
me quickly go over some key points in
that video before i get into how bad of
a situation
intel is in today and to make things
interesting
i'm gonna be referring to the five
stages of grief
to chart where intel is at at each point
in the story
so let's get right into it in the early
2000s and 2010s
intel enjoyed the bulk of the cpu market
share
especially for gaming so they got a bit
cocky in 2013
and announced a very optimistic cpu
roadmap
promising that they'd be shipping
nanometer chips
in 2015. to do that they were gonna use
a brand new chip making technology
against the wishes of some of their
engineers and it ended up getting
delayed over and over and over again
all the way out to 2019 by the way intel
was in the first stage of grief during
that time
denial now while that was happening amd
came out of the shadows with their
impressive ryzen
and threadripper cpus which caused some
serious pain to intel
and we know this because intel started
lowering the prices of their chips
to compete with amd on top of that
within just a couple of years
intel very quickly upped the core count
on their desktop trips
from 4 cores all the way up to 10
trying to keep up with amd all while
using the same
old 14 nanometer chip architecture this
actually caused a lot of pain for apple
because the company literally redesigned
their 2016
super thin and light macbook pro with
intel's
10 nanometer chips in mind which were
supposed to be ready
by 2015 but they weren't and because of
that major delay
apple's macbook pros started having
major overheating issues
and apple took the blame for all of the
disappointment by their consumers
but thankfully in june of 2020
apple made perhaps the best decision
they could have
ever made they announced the switch away
from intel
over to their own apple silicon chips
essentially the same chips that come
in an ipad or an iphone just
souped up for high performance and now
we know
just how good of a decision that was by
apple
because intel's brand new 11th gen
desktop cpus are still being
built on a 14 nanometer process
which is just shameful at this point and
by the way
11 days before apple announced the
transition
intel's lead chip architect resigned
showing that they knew this was coming
and at this point in the story
they were well into the anger stage of
their grief
and then of course later in 2020 apple
revealed
their new m1 chip and ever since then
it's been an absolute slaughter fest for
intel
with the m1 max completely embarrassing
every intel base mac machine
out there in terms of performance power
usage and value
and based on the incredible sales data
for apple's new m1 max
it looks like consumers are all for
ditching intel
for apple's new custom chips oh and by
the way
intel got rid of their ceo bob swann
earlier this year more anger and now
here we are in april of 2021
and intel is doing things that we never
thought they'd do in a million years
they actually stole the mac guy from
apple's most famous ad
campaign and turned him against the mac
showing that he's now beginning to
prefer windows based laptops instead
this is perhaps the biggest act of
desperation
that intel has ever displayed once again
more anger but here's the thing about
intel's
new ad campaign that many people don't
realize
intel doesn't actually make windows
based laptops
they simply make chips for any platform
that wants some so they made an ad
campaign
against apple products even though they
don't make
any hardware products of their own to be
honest it should have been
microsoft the creators of windows who
ran
this ad campaign and not intel which is
ironic
so intel is basically sucking up to
microsoft
and windows based laptop makers which
shows how
desperately intel wants to keep their
business
just look at this image telling you to
quote go
pc but wait it gets even worse
and this is where the bargaining stage
of grief comes in
just days after their anti-apple ad
campaign launched
intel ceo mentioned that they want to
manufacture
apple silicon chips in the future yes
they actually had the guts
to say this in public after that ad
campaign which shows
just how desperate they are now why in
the world would they want to do this
well for security if their own x86 chips
start to lose market share at least
they'll be able to survive
by producing the very chips that led to
their demise
but in my opinion i don't think there's
any way that intel is getting apple's
business
ever again and here's why apple got
burned
many times by intel in the past from the
whole 10 nanometer chip delay
causing them embarrassment due to
overheating macbooks
to the various intel security flaws that
apple had to take the heat for
i don't think that apple wants to play
with fire again
and by the way apple has already
reserved years worth of chip orders with
tsmc
the most advanced chipmaker in the world
which seems to be the most resilient
to the global chip shortage that we're
currently going through
and since apple is tsmc's number one
customer
they will do everything possible to keep
up with the chip demand
specifically for apple so there's really
no point for apple to go with intel
especially since they're behind in terms
of chip making technology
so yeah intel is desperate and the worst
part of all
is that apple is just getting started
yes the m1 max are killing it
but it's the m1x macbook pros which are
gonna revolutionize the entire industry
and finally put the last nail in intel's
coffin
and put them into the next stage of
grief depression
so let's get into why the future looks
so grim for intel
right now in 2021 laptop manufacturers
have already started to offer
amd cpu models alongside intel versions
of their laptops
so intel is already losing market share
on that front
but on the other side apple's m1 max are
so impressive
that some laptop makers are reportedly
looking forward
to arm-based chips instead of x86
but they haven't seen nothing yet based
on our own estimates
the m1x macbook pros coming sometime
this fall
should be able to easily outperform
every single intel based macbook
at a fraction of the price but the most
important detail to consider
is that the power efficiency of these
macbooks
should be incredible thanks to how
efficient apple's arm-based chips have
proved to be
so there's a very good chance that the
m1x macbooks
will literally be the best laptops ever
made
and sooner or later the entire laptop
industry
will begin moving over to using
arm-based chips
and right now both samsung and qualcomm
are quietly sitting in the shadows with
their arm chips
waiting for this to happen and even
worse the folks over at microsoft the
makers of windows
have already announced that they're
going to be making arm-based chips of
their own
and going even further they've been
focusing more and more on updating
their arm-based version of windows ever
since
apple announced their transition this is
very bad
news for intel because if microsoft
makes the switch to arm based chips
it's going to show where the entire
industry is moving
since microsoft will be incentivized to
make the armed version of windows
the best that it can be to compete with
apple
so if the entire industry begins
transitioning to arm-based ships
then intel is basically screwed because
they're 13 generation raptor lake chips
coming in 2022 seem to still be using
the same x86 10 nanometer process as the
12th gen
alder lake which by the way isn't even
here yet
this puts intel in the worst possible
position because it's clear
that they're still not working on
arm-based designs
if they were they would have already
announced it in an attempt to make their
investors happy
but they didn't and by far the worst
thing is that their main competitor amd
is reported to be already working on
some arm-based chips of their own
to battle apple's m chips so when intel
does
eventually announce that they're working
on arm chip designs
it's probably going to be too late now i
know that some of you are going to say
that apple was only a small part of
intel's business
so it's not really going to matter sales
wise but one thing
is very clear the user sentiment towards
intel
has been rapidly changing to the
negative side
and that is more important than anything
else and just in case you're gonna say
that the book of intel's business
is actually the server or workstation
market
i've got some more bad news for you the
fastest servers in the world
are already using arm-based designs and
intel's future xeon road map
is purely x86 based and here is where
the other side of the danger lies
companies who host massive servers
require
many computers which causes a couple of
problems that need to be dealt with
first there's a huge amount of power
that's required to run the computers
and second there's the huge amount of
heat that the computers
output so they need massive cooling
systems
in order to keep them cool which also
use
tons of power we already showed this off
when we compared the performance per
watt
of apple's m1 mac mini to the
intel-based mac
pro the difference is massive so if
arm-based chips require
less power and less cooling while still
having awesome performance
why wouldn't the server or workstation
industry
move over to arm they're going to save
massive amounts of cash
just in electricity and cooling expenses
alone
scaleway is already offering cloud
services
using apple m1 mac minis for only 12
cents an hour
compared to amazon's web services which
use intel mac minis
for over a dollar an hour and people are
already surprised by the price
and it's all due to the power savings of
the m1 chip
oh and by the way amazon has already
announced that they're going to have
m1 mac minis available soon as well
so it looks like the server industry is
already
slowly beginning to switch to arm so to
sum up this entire video
apple basically triggered the death of
intel
with their apple silicon transition and
at this point
it's looking like intel's only way out
will be to start work on arm-based
designs
as soon as possible but at this point
they haven't been so i guess we'll just
have to wait and see
what the future holds for intel
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video
and if you learned something new go
ahead and click the circle above to
subscribe for more videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
videos including the last version of
this video that we made
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video